hello everyone we will be starting in
two minutes and in the meantime those
who have joined just now it would be
great if you could introduce yourself in
the chat box like your educational
background where you're coming from and
what are your research interests like we
have
charles and richard introducing
themselves just like that
so we'll be starting in two minutes
we're just waiting for rest of the
participants to join
i have a question who all are available
for this webinar like eligible i mean
hello bunch thank you for that question
yes uh the high school training programs
as you can see on the screen so it's uh
the eligibility is for
students who are in from 8th grade to
12th grade as well as who are beginners
and maybe undergraduates
who would want to
understand how bioinformatics and data
science is applied in biomedical and
other research which what we would be
covering in today's session and
uh letting everyone know that how this
will be
does that answer your question one
all right let's start
today's webinar
um
hello everyone my name is shrigari and i
would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on omixlogic
bioinformatics high school training
programs
and before proceeding further let us
discuss what the high school programs
are all about
so to begin with the high school pro
summer programs provide students great
opportunities to pursue new interests
improve existing skills and brainstorm
with like-minded students and although
bioinformatics and data science
continues to redefine the way research
is carried out it has barely been
incorporated into the high school
education system to address this
disparity mind biotech has launched the
omics logic high school summer training
programs specifically designed to meet
the needs and interests of high school
students in the following areas of
interest that is biomedical data science
using r and python genomics and virtual
lab and independent research project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me briefly introduce you to the team
behind the program we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy-to-use
analytical tools and make bioinformatics
more accessible
and over the past several years we have
had the privilege of working with a
number of organizations developing a
training program for research oriented
students faculty and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students and
faculty around the world
the omics logic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
now to mention the educational
objectives the omixlogic training
follows a project-based learning
approach using research-grade tools to
analyze data from top peer-reviewed
journals omixlogic training has been
completed by students researchers and
faculty in six different specialization
tracks including oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
the omex logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine our
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
i would like to introduce you to the
founders and team members of the company
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one of his main
projects is the establishment of the
toba bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
doctor leonard brodsky is the director
of toba bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics our platform is a result
of hard work by some of the people
mentioned here on the right dr julia
panel is an expert bioinformatician
abby tavisky leads the development of
the t bioinfo platform dr mohit mazumdar
is an experienced bioinformatician with
multiple publications in top peer review
journals and he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project lead for omix logic
training and research fellowship
and dr raghvan lakshmi narayan is an
accomplished computation biologist with
experience in large-scale analysis of
multi-or mixed data and data science
methods in precision oncology protein or
dna structural bioinformatics
all right so now let's highlight some of
the current challenges and limitations
and how omics logic helped resolve these
with our training and research services
so to discuss some of the challenges
that the field of bioinformatics is
facing currently to begin with
this field is constantly growing and
developing new technology and software
to improve processing time and power the
data sets that are analyzed are usually
very large and take immense amount of
computing power and memory that many
personal computers do not have
also despite publicly available data
they're also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have
and in a university setting students
have the opportunity to learn the
background information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics projects
but
do not receive practical hands-on
experience with a full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly
face challenges with being able to cover
a diverse range of topics if they're
specialized in a certain area of
bioinformatics or if they are unfamiliar
with bioinformatics in general for
example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expression might not
know about the meta genomics of seawater
to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologists or clinicians and some
pro problems for standardization
materials for these courses are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated
and the organization because the
challenge is to combine several
different topics together the flow and
transitions are needed to be developed
systematization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or
allows someone to run forward omixlogic
uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concepts to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project-based approach
now to discuss about the learning
process in order to create a clear path
of skill development omics logic employs
the bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
now what this is this approach starts
with the basics students recall facts
and terminology and are able to repeat
and memorize the material and with this
base the learning builds to conceptual
knowledge being able to understand
concepts and apply information to new
situations
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omix logic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge and
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path up the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid
no matter what the initial user's
experience is regarding bioinformatics
omix logic is a useful tool for gaining
a baseline knowledge of the theory
behind bioinformatics analysis of large
data sets and introduction to basic
coding languages like r and python or
beginning a data analysis project
and the users will be given directions
to access the t by info platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
analysis cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipeline and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on the multi-omics
platform
this program comes with an access to the
omicrologic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics precision
medicine multiomics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python are
also covered
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work as displayed on
the slide including projects such as
single cell rna-seq to tcga liver cancer
risk
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic learn portal we'll
share the link to the portal in the chat
box and i'll wait for a couple of
moments so that users can sign up on the
portal and we'll resume after that so
once you have signed up on the portal
please put a yes in the chat box so that
i know when to proceed
sparsh has shared the link to the portal
so once you have signed up please put a
yes in the chat box if you have if
you're facing any technical challenges
you can mention that
and our team will be here to help you
sort through it
all right harish has um
signed up on the portal
yes uh richard it is uh you can sign up
on the portal so that you can browse
through and see what are the various
courses and example projects that we
have to offer
so that you can align your interest
accordingly
all right so
proceeding to the next part so once you
have signed up on the portal this is
what that you'll be seeing
so in an updated profile uh a completed
profile will uh will have the following
that is a profile picture as you can see
on the slide the full name with proper
capitalization link to your social media
handles that could be your facebook
linkedin instagram arc id or twitter and
a brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and mentioning your research interest
and under the uh
tabs various tabs that you can see the
mentors can view your progress and the
courses that you're currently doing will
appear under the courses tab and after
completing a course your certificates
will appear under the certificates tab
all right so now let's
quickly i'll just quickly take you
through the signing do we go on the
basic table in this case i have since
i've already signed up i have the email
id and the password already saved but if
you are new to the uh platform you can
use a either use
google account or your facebook or
twitter
or github account to login which will be
easier for you or you can also sign up
using your email id just like i did
so now i'm going to sign in to the
portal and i'll take you through the
all right so if you click on the tab
that says welcome back with your email
id that will take you to your profile
and a completed profile will have just
like i said
your name would property capitalization
a link to your social media handle so in
my case i've linked the linkedin and my
arc id and then i've mentioned my
educational background and my research
interest and the activity that is at the
end of the activity tab you can view
your progress and this is cl this is the
place where the profits uh the mentors
will also be tracking your progress and
you have the courses tab the projects
tab and the programs tab
so once you have logged in you can
browse through and check the diverse
range of courses and example projects
that we have to offer so to move on to
the next part of the session i would
like to invite mr elia brodsky who will
give you a high over overview level of
the topics that will be covered during
the program
thank you sri guri and just briefly
answering some of the questions here in
the chat so first of all if you have
already signed up you have a profile
there's no need to resign up
this is just to make sure that you have
access because we'll be referencing some
of the things that we'll
have on the portal
the second question is what to do after
you sign up you get redirected to a
pricing page
you know there's no need to pay for
anything right now this is just to give
you access so just navigate away from
the pricing page
and
as we go through the program it will be
more clear
how the different resources can be used
so
in my part of the presentation i will
briefly talk about what the
level topics are that we're going to
cover
and discuss how you might benefit from
participating in the program what might
be the possible outcomes i'll introduce
you to some of the mentors that will be
helping you along the way and show you
some examples of students that have
completed this program and what they
have done with the information that they
received
so as you all know
we live in the age of data and
specifically in biomedical research or
in biology there's a growing
source of data and one data in
particular called next generation
sequencing data is becoming
kind of the foundation of a lot of the
different research topics that are being
done in biomedical research and
agriculture and biotechnology etc so my
background is actually not in
bioinformatics but i came into
bioinformatics by working with pine
biotech and the different collaborators
that include multiple research
universities
biomedical
research projects and consortia and i've
had the privilege of
training uh and
working alongside experts and students
in many different institutions here in
the us
so as a result of that
i've seen how
it's really unpredictable to know
who becomes uh you know an expert and
and who leaves and who kind of chooses
bioinformatics is their topic and for a
lot of people what i've discovered is
it's not clear what bioinformatics
actually is and how is it applied in a
variety of domains
so my first part of today's session is
to explain why bioinformatics and what
is bioinformatics and how data in
biomedical research is actually used to
advance the application of insights from
such analyses to
advanced precision medicine
biotechnology agriculture etc so
first of all kind of a historical
background since the
1950s when the dna was first discovered
the structure of dna was clarified we've
seen how such information has led to
nudity discoveries starting from the
sequencing annotation and discovery of
the human genome and the genes that are
responsible for different proteins to
technologies that make such data easy to
produce
and eventually to use
in large-scale initiatives like genomics
england
the broad institute
different
medical centers that actually use
insights from genomic data to categorize
diagnose and treat patients
now the basis of that is that
when we understand the code and we
understand what the code actually uh
produces so how nucleotide sequences
form amino acid sequences that are the
basis of proteins
we can start looking at variation of
that dna code that is responsible for
some specific phenotype or in this case
in this example you can see sickle cell
anemia actually a change in a particular
amino acid leads to a change in
a cell structure right
and so
that kind of an ability to
detect changes
has led to
a number of very clear applications so
for example drug metabolism how
different individuals metabolize
different drugs and whether they will
respond or not respond to treatment
identification of mutations and cancer
cells identifying genetic predisposition
or disorders like sickle cell
anemia inherited mutations
rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance and different
pathogens and these examples are all in
the context of biomedical research and
medical application in the context of
precision or personalized medicine
because what happens in the medical
context is today clinicians have to deal
with such information to actually make
a better um description or
characterization of disease for a
patient and and one of the things that
we now are starting to see is that you
have these panels of
specific genes specific
proteins
and
you can now identify mutations that are
responsible for
very dangerous diseases like cancer now
as researchers continue to study these
they actually understand that
some specific genes in the genome are
responsible for the most uh serious
effects so for example tumor suppressor
genes oncode genes dna repair genes they
accumulate mutations that are most
dangerous one example is the tp-53
mutation that
is a gene p53 protein
tumor protein p53 is encoded in that
gene and what that mutation does is it
can actually alter the structure of that
protein and make it not functional and
if it's not functional it's a tumor
suppressor gene so then it does not
suppress the tumor growth because it
does not respond to the damage in the
dna and leads to accumulation of
mutations so finding such mutations can
be critical for accurate and precise and
effective cancer cancer treatment
in cystic fibrosis
you have uh mutations that are
responsible for the functioning of uh
the cftr channel
which is responsible for uh getting the
right kind of uh
chloride ions out of the cells and if
it's not functioning it leads to
accumulation of mucus and can be very
dangerous so knowing how to find these
mutations and understand their function
is clearly important and not only is
this important for individual mutations
this is also important for large scale
rearrangements like copy number
variation uh repeats that expand a
particular region and and one way to
find those variations is to perform
genome-wide analyses that take thousands
of samples for clear phenotypes and
start understanding what are the
statistically significant patterns that
occur in a large proportion of the
population such studies have led to
discoveries including tuberculosis drug
resistance which is a disease that is
affecting millions of individuals around
the world
if someone can monitor the participants
and make sure that no one
thinks if you could keep them unmuted
thank you
so drug resistance
not only to individual drugs but
multiple drugs is starting to become a
huge problem
and and we see the same in the
world of viral pathogens so for example
the ebola outbreak and how that leads to
tracking of transmission and vaccine
design but also the current pandemic of
covert 19 we hear about variance of
concern all the time so all of these
project examples all of these
you know examples in precision medicine
in population health
genetic predisposition to disease all of
these have been transformed by the
availability of these different types of
sequencing techniques so in the program
what we will try to do is introduce you
to how such data is generated
what is the process of acquiring actual
digital data from a biological sample
and then in that data set how do we work
with
different algorithms computational
algorithms to understand mutations that
are pathogenic neutral
that are maybe not very bad or bad
and how do we determine the effect of
these mutations in the genome so how do
we actually categorize them how do we
understand their impact on the phenotype
and what are some examples where you can
find uh the you know clear association
between individual mutations and the
phenotype
and so that is really what
bioinformatics is all about so
bioinformatics is about taking
information or data
taking methods of computational analysis
statistical methods machine learning
analytical methods and applying them to
biological data sets applying them to
data sets where we have biological
samples conditions clinical conditions
etc and so the program is going to
tie together these three different
domains
in a way that you can quickly see the
application of bioinformatics to a
number of different domains
so the omixlogic
programs are going to help you not only
understand how these things work but
also practice and apply them and so in
the context of this program these
resources that were already mentioned by
sri geri are going to be critical to
getting you from maybe not knowing a lot
about bioinformatics to getting an
understanding of what bioinformatics is
and how it applies to eventually
starting to use it maybe in your own
project or a group
and so here
we're going to try to cover a variety of
different types of
examples or projects that are case
studies that you can use
to really understand and develop a sense
of you personally discovering something
on your own using some of these tools
now i imagine that most of you here have
understanding of what bioinformatics is
maybe not a lot of experience and that
is really who the program is for
now i want to specifically highlight
two
project or two resources
on the onyx logic portal
where you can get started so even if
you're here for the first time now that
you have registered you can go to the
omixlogic portal and find two specific
courses one is called introduction to
bioinformatics
and another one is called bytes and
molecules so sparse or trigori somebody
maybe can
yeah someone can maybe post the links
so if you have
an account and you've signed up again
the sign up is free
those are two introductory courses that
will get you started they will get you
into this context that will explain at a
high level the different applications
and introduce you to our community the
way that things are organized and you
will really get a good sense of why
bioinformatics is it for me and what can
i do with it
okay thank you tash so introduction to
bioinformatics is that first course and
the second course that i wanted to
mention is called bytes and molecules
so again if you search here bytes and
molecules it is course two and this
course is
different from the introduction to
bioinformatics because it is a little
bit more detailed and actually
introduces a lot of the concepts that
are going to be useful for what we do in
this program and that includes
terminology or what are these terms like
snips
you know variants gene expression
profiles etc it will give you a sense of
the relationship between
code
and structure and how things work in the
cell
and then it will introduce you to
specific types of data that could be
that could be acquired from next
generation sequencing so genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics and
talk a little bit about maybe things
that you haven't thought of how
bioinformatics is actually used to study
precision medicine or astronaut health
in space
now also a big component of
bioinformatics as i mentioned is the
application of data analysis techniques
and tools to large data sets and coding
is a critical component so as you've
seen one of the critical elements is to
understand how and why and then have the
practical skills and so the second
option that was mentioned in the
beginning so the first one was genomics
in the virtual lab the second one was
coding or biomedical data analysis in r
and python so in this course you will
already get an introduction to coding in
r which is a popular
method of analyzing different types of
biological data where you will have
access to different examples of just
getting to know what coding is why do we
need coding and how to read
use
to load the data things like that so
that's going to be very useful because
one of the practical examples here is
the ability to actually run code and
practice fixing the code that is given
to you without having to
you know
take too much time of
yours
to actually learn everything from
scratch so we're not going to learn
things like hello world we're going to
jump into how to load data and this data
is going to be biological data or the
type of data that you are expected to
use in the domain of
bioinformatics and once we get into this
you will see that you will start to
appreciate syntax you will know how to
load and produce
simple plots that are informative you
will
interpret these plots and then as it
becomes more and more complex so here
you will find assignments
those will introduce you to more and
more complex methods of analysis
including analysis of complex data
analysis using complex methods like
machine learning and deep learning and
also ability to integrate multiple
sources of information to actually
answer real research questions
so along the way as you go through this
coursework you will realize that a lot
of this course work is sourced from
experts in the field
and experts in the field are people that
have a long history
of
maybe doing research or using such
skills in the domain of biotechnology
and pharma
and getting to know these people you
will realize that they all have a rich
history and a path of how they got to
where they are today so
to briefly introduce some of these
people
i want to
highlight a couple examples
and those examples are going to
demonstrate kind of the quality of the
people that you will be
exposed to so let me just open that
video real quick
and what i will play is a short video
about a couple of
people
that will
that have contributed to the development
of the coursework that we will be
sampling
and hopefully that will clarify
uh who these uh
people are and then i will pass it on to
dr raghav who will speak from his
personal experience about his
um about his mentorship experience um
and what he does with that now
okay can you hear me
let me know if you can uh hear this
i'm very excited
and so um what's interesting though is
as i was preparing this talk
um i realized that today is 25 years to
the day since i started my postdoc
and so i had just finished my phd work
under the direct direction of dr bruce
rowe at the university of oklahoma where
we were sequencing regions of human
chromosome 22 as part of the human
genome project and on april 1 1997 i
began my postdoctoral study at the nih
under the direction of dr francis
collins now i can tell you if you've
never started a new job on april fool's
day it is quite the experience
and so as the new green post talk i was
immediately the april fool and the easy
target of many practical jokes in my new
lab
but what i didn't realize at that point
was that this was the beginning of a
translational career built on genomics
and its application to human health and
so i was fortunate to not only
contribute sequencing data to the human
genome project but to also be in the
epicenter of human genomic research in
the u.s upon completion of the human
genome reference sequence in 2003. so at
that time i was infused with optimism
about what we could do to understand
human health and disease how we could
further understand what makes each of us
alike but also what makes each of us
different so how are we different in our
responses to environmental stimuli to
pharmaceutical drugs to chemotherapy
and since this day in 1997 i've studied
cancer and performed large-scale
transcriptomic analyses of several tumor
and cancer syndromes i've worked in the
drug development pharmaceutical industry
and then now here we are 25 years later
i'm translating what i've learned in
each of these very research environments
to supporting patient management in our
cap accredited clinical precision
medicine laboratory
so really as you can see
the the people who have worked
in this domain for many decades
and have now been able to apply what
they have learned and study to actual
practical applications are the types of
people that you will need throughout
this program virtually and be able to
work through problems that represent the
type of work that they do to really
understand the impact of bioinformatics
in the domains of precision medicine
basic and translational research and so
with that i would like to introduce you
to a mentor will help you throughout
these projects
and his name is dr
uh
ragavandran lakshmi narayan
he will
be one of the mentors
that will guide you to the project so um
dr raghav over to you
hey thank you very much elia i think
something's wrong with my video let me
fix it
[Music]
yeah i think that should work
yes perfect thank you very much leia let
me find ways to share my screen
so can you see my screen and my audible
yes both yes perfect thank you very much
uh so uh
i am raghavindran lakshmi narayan i'm a
research consultant and bioinformatics
mentor with pine biot
uh it's very uh
it's wonderful to see you all and
welcome to this session
i'm trained in bioinformatics and i hold
a computational biology
phd degree from max prank institute
germany so my research interest and
focus
is on the application of variety of data
science techniques such as machine
learning approaches deep learning
approaches towards the translation
studies of cancer biology towards
applying to plant genetics and
neurological disorder etc so my role in
this company includes mentoring a
variety of students like you students
who are from high school students who
are from bachelors students who are
doing master's and all the way up to
students who are pursuing phds
so
please let me introduce you about my
background and how we started in the
field of bioinformatics research
so the impact of human genome project in
a variety of biological research field
is very well known and documented so in
fact this very discussion that we are
having and the meeting is a result of
this extraordinary project
so this project affected my career as
well so when the findings of human
genome research project was announced
and its promise inspired me
to pursue a
career in biology
from
from jumping fields from being a
physicist
so i completed my masters in biophysics
and bioinformatics being
under graduation in being under
undergraduate in
physics and followed by which i joined
max planck institute in germany to
work on my phd thesis
so after that my two postdoctoral
research tenures from uh india from
institute of bioinformatics and applied
biotechnology bengaluru and jawaharlal
nehru university
this is where um it was instrumental in
helping me develop a deeper
understanding
in the
in the area of bioinformatics research
applications to variety of different
data sets so for the past eight months i
am part of this wonderful company which
gives me opportunity to share my
learning to inspiring students like you
so over the course of my career or over
the course of my tenure i have been
involved in projects from variety of
different backgrounds that includes
protein structural biology that includes
agriculture uh that includes multi-omics
data analysis like uh genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics data etc and
these all mixed data acquired from a
variety of different uh sources like
model systems
like from patient resources unlike from
agricultural sources and etc so this
variety of projects and this
wide spectrum has been immensely helpful
for me to tending to students with a
wide range of interest and in
in pursuing a research training with us
so to give you an idea of uh
of my research
interest and background give let me
share one of the interesting projects
that i was involved in
during my career
so this is a project on precision
oncology and to introduce you to
precision oncology uh first let me tell
that
most of you would have already known
oncology is a study of cancer biology
and we know that cancer is the leading
cause of disease states worldwide for
such a dreadful disease decision for
disease with such an impact um
systematic carrier treatments have
relied on drugs which are
chemotherapeutic drugs and these drugs
are marginally more toxic to the cancer
cells than normal states i mean such an
approach is is not very ideal and it
gives us our results in a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond
positively to these cancer products but
in comparison
over 80 percentage of the patients
respond to popular painkillers like
aspirin that you get over the count
so one of the prominent solution to this
problem is precision ontology so
precision ontological therapy is is a is
a strategy
where the treatment is actually designed
by targeting the molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
so hence the treatment that is given to
the patients are personalized to the
to those patients who are likely to
respond to specific therapies and
therapeutic approaches
so the way that we have approached or
the way that i have addressed this
precision oncological
problem issue
is to implement data-driven approaches
to include multi-omics data for
understanding and for predicting
patients response to a variety of cancer
treatments
so how do i do this
the tumor cells that that form cancer in
patients are
collected in during biopsy and are then
subjected to next generation sequencing
techniques and the information about
gene expression the information about a
mutation and the information about
epigenetic variation that characterizes
the gene expression were extracted and
they were recorded
this data or these omics data
molecularly characterizes the tumor so
these are different from from
different types of tumor and different
subtypes of human and then these tumor
samples are then
grafted or then administered
several cancer drugs and their response
is studied by
measuring their volume
so this data records the tumors reaction
and response to different treatments
some for some treatments the tumor will
diminish in volume and for some of the
treatments it will not
respond positively so these responses
and the molecular
characterization data characterize data
were then integrated and various
machine learning algorithms and deep
learning algorithms were applied to
understand how they are related so from
this relationship we were able to
predict which patient or which cancer
from which patients
were able to positively or will be able
to respond positively to the treatment
that is that they are subjected to or
from the list of multiple treatments so
this is how we approach
understanding cancer biology from
multi-org data different approaches so
projects like these and various other
projects and uh example projects
methodologies and resources are compiled
and explained um
expertly in the learn omix logic
platform so while you are enrolled in
specific programs that addresses your
interest you are also welcome to explore
various such resources under example
projects and expand your horizons in the
field of bioinformatics data analysis
so as i have already mentioned my main
involvement in this
is with the students
who are enrolled with research
fellowship program
this research fellowship program is
designed to address key challenges that
every student will face
while
subjecting or while opting for a
bioinformatics research so if you are
interested in extending your enrollment
for research fellowship program after
the completion of your specific program
then you would also
be able to leverage all the resources
that are developed to overcome these key
challenges like
time involved in learning and testing
out a lot of different strategies
and time and access to bioinformatics
expertise and access to
big data infrastructure
so
who will benefit from a research
fellowship program like this and who
what will the students like you take
away
from this research fellowship program
so for students who are new to
bioinformatics and who does not have an
early exposure to bioinformatics this
gives you an excellent opportunity to
develop an exposure to the methods to
the logic behind these methods and
analysis and to practice your knowledge
that we have gained
throughout this program uh into a
research project that interests you or
research project that will help you in
your care
and for students who have some exposure
to bioinformatics and who already know a
little bit of bioinformatics you will
gain expert feedback and project
evaluation
that will take your project from a
superficial investigation
to
superficial investigation
to a full-fledged research project that
fulfills many prominent criteria for
being a successful publication so you
will also be interacting with mentors
like me and dr mohit and elia and
understand where and how to find complex
data assets that is going to help you
design a very specific bioinformatics
project and this project as i have
already mentioned can be developed or
can be
designed with an aim to obtain a
research publication by the end of your
trainer
so with that i will conclude my
presentation and i look forward to
interact with all of you during the
program and see most of you for the
research fellowship program
and what happened
yes so now i will pass the stage to dr
mohit mazumdar to who will talk about
the highlights and curriculum of this
summer
over to you dr mohamed
uh thank you dr raghav and hello
everyone
my name is dr mohit and
i'm going to share my screen
with you all so that we can
go through the curriculums that we have
designed for
this summer
for and all the opportunities that are
available
so
i'll start from this page the page that
has been shared with you and many of you
might have visited this page so this is
the page that describes the
high school summer training program in
uh much more detail and you'll find a
lot of resources here a lot of
information that will help you
understand more about the design and
more about the curriculum more about the
topics and more about the schedule of
the
program's upcoming
sessions on all of that
so let's let's begin
with the with an overview as you've
already learned that what are the major
topics and how we are going to do this
and
if
during this
presentation
if you have any question please feel
free to
uh let me know by putting it in the chat
or on muting yourself so
as we are having the first webinar here
and we are discussing about the program
we are going to offer three different
types of training which will be
available for all of you interested to
participate in so
these three type of trainings will
include uh different types of topics
different types of outcome so let me
explain that like very briefly uh so we
have uh listed out some of the
advantages and how this uh training was
is going to be uh including what all
topics and how the system works you you
already created a login online so that
will help you
uh to orient yourself and get
comfortable with the resources that
we'll be sharing so
you have an option uh as i was saying i
was saying that uh we are going to uh
we are going to uh invite students to
join these programs which are available
so how do we learn about what what will
be the topics
and how which dates they will be
covered and what what will be the
resources which will be uh you know put
together for those sessions so let's
take a look at by clicking these
specific programs so we have listed out
here like four programs from learning
about genomics and working with an
expert to do some genomic research
utilizing different resources then to
learn about biomedical data science
using coding
by applying rn python and then to be
able to do your own research by
participating in an independent research
project so from understanding very
beginner level uh beginner level
courses by understanding and going
through the mentor and the support team
you will be able to develop that
understanding of how to utilize big data
and how to utilize these different
applications that you heard of so i
think in this meeting and during the
call uh we uh you might have heard many
terms which were new to you um
if that is true please let me know if
say put uh yes in the chat box so
for you to learn about those new
keywords and new terminologies we have
prepared a lot of uh resources that will
definitely going to help you go through
uh them strategically so let me let's
first go through the first program uh so
you know uh genomics in the virtual lab
very special program where we have a
excellent mentor
who will take you professor sona
vasudevan from georgetown university a
very prestigious university in the us
and along with our mentors which uh
which we will start
from 18th july and uh it will be
available for you to enroll for uh one
and a half months that is 45 days uh
training or a 60 day training or a
90-day training based on your
availability and the time that you can
allocate for such training so um that's
the timeline for the program to start
you will also find like a
overview and you can see that how the
previous year student presented and we
will be going through some of these uh
outcomes of the program because it's
important to understand that what
happens after the program what are the
things that we're gonna learn and if
there is some projects that we're going
to work on so we will be talking about
that but before that let me take you
through the schedule first and a little
bit about how do you join the program so
uh 18th of july we have the first
session which is introduction to
bioinformatics very basic uh which
involves uh understanding of formix
technologies role of big data in
biomedicines and then
different repositories resources and
tools how to access the learn omics
logic and its projects and courses how
to access the topper bioinformatics
research platform and
start you know using some of the
pipelines so it's very exciting but yeah
we will start with a very basic overview
of how that uh all of this is going to
work for you so that is the first
session which is scheduled for
july 18th which will be
a live session then we have these
different sessions uh which will be
asynchronously available which means
that you will be getting the recording
and you will be getting all the
resources and whatever you need for to
learn the topics that are going to cover
uh on july 22nd and an opportunity
for you to help
understand some of the concepts some of
the topics some of the problems that you
face so there will be a team supporting
all of this then we have the next
section which is more about
understanding how uh we can do
comparative sequence analysis how can we
correlate it with the with the
evolutionary analysis so we will learn
about sequences from sequences we will
understand how sequences fold into
three-dimensional structure and how do
we analyze the structure from sequence
how do we analyze those uh
three-dimensionally model structure in
in our laptops in our systems and
understand about different types of uh
mutations maybe that causes the
important uh or
changes in the body right so we will be
learning about all of those from
sequence to structure and then to
function and to understand function we
will take some of the case studies and
we will review um some of the diseases
types that we have described and
discussed in this webinar previously so
i'll not go into the detail but one of
the activity that is planned and which
will be one of the uh i mean
landmarks or highlights of this program
is that you will have an opportunity
after the first five session to work on
a small project and showcase it's like a
more of a review to find out some of the
insights from what you have learned and
apply to some of the projects that we we
are
letting you know or you can
also give your own proposal so this
weekend activity will include preparing
a couple of slides and sharing with us
and discussing if you can work on this
project if this project is feasible or
if this research is feasible so that
would be uh about you know finding a
research question followed by that there
will be specialized sessions which will
cover very important topics uh for for
research and very important topics for
you know learning which is to how do you
do literature review and how do you
design a project and then how what are
the different elements that will be
designed inside the project so on august
8 we have that session where we'll be
sharing you how to design a
bioinformatics research project how to
do literature review and all of that and
then we will dive into some sort of
specializations which is like virology
here the virology
you all have written as the covid
pandemic and we will be learning about
different aspects of virology and how
bioinformatics is applied in biology and
it will involve uh uh involve
uh understanding of how do you apply
some basic
r uh programming by understanding uh and
utilizing some sequences and then
playing it in the code playground and
then doing it in the code playground as
you have seen so followed by that we
have some sessions on microbial
communities where we will learn about
metagenomics because it's very important
now to correlate between these different
uh
technologies and the data that they
produce so it actually helps us in you
know developing a very good research
project so all of these sessions are
kind of designed to help you
develop that understanding the ideas
that ideas will automatically
automatically come when you
when you understand that how they are
applied in different case case studies
and how they are applied in terms of you
know doing it uh by doing it yourself on
uh tbi info platform uh using the
hands-on analysis and then we have some
case studies uh which involves you know
vaccine antibody and antiviral drugs and
analysis of genome or ncbi viruses where
we will be exploring the public
repositories because
a lot of data and huge huge amount of
data are being deposited every day and i
and we all think that there is an
opportunity to investigate further into
those data sets big data sets which is
usually very difficult to do but
otherwise it will be much easier through
the program and through the resources
that we'll be sharing and that's an
opportunity for all of you to take now
uh after this first uh the second half
of the program where you will understand
and go through all of these public
repositories tools to use and uh
technologies to apply you will have an
opportunity to do a project presentation
where you come up with your own idea and
we will be there will be judges
from academia and industry and we have
an amazing panel of judges uh from uh
who are from top universities leaders in
their field
can give you really good feedback about
how the project is shaping up so that's
how the program is planned and after
26th of august till the end of your
program we you will have an opportunity
to discuss with the mentors and the team
and work on your research project and
research proposal and uh if you have a
good research project proposal then
there's an opportunity for you to join
the research fellowship and work on an
independent research project that i'll
come next
but before that uh let me take you to
the registration process so if you have
already created
your uh login here what all you have to
do is just uh you know go to this page
and then go to this section where you
can choose a subscription click the
subscription button where you want to
choose the subscription and then go
through these simple steps and complete
your registration if you're
from low income country group then you
are
eligible for scholarship and you'll be
able
all you have to do is that write
an email to us
suggesting the same
and we will be able to guide you with
the scholarship process now going back
to the second program we have these
different opportunities that we have we
have been discussing so please feel free
to ask any questions related to the
program that we are discussing the next
program is focused more on your data
science more on doing coding more on
learning how to apply data science
techniques into
using biomedical or biological data so
maybe some of you are more interested in
data science some of you are more
interested in investigating or doing
biological research so
uh it is based on your
interest you can join and choose between
these programs so now the next program
that i wanted to show you is the data
science program which is going to start
very soon on 4th july where we will be
going through the basics of programming
for everyone to get you know um
get to know about uh the get on get on
the same page perhaps because we have
students coming from different
backgrounds and many of uh many of those
students do not have a background of
programming at all so we have these very
beginner level sessions to help students
learn from the uh the mentors about
these uh how to get started and then
installing and going through the very
basics like vectors matrices libraries
and then start utilizing once you start
utilizing you start working with
sequences you learn about you know how
to process data and we start visualizing
in r and then you go into different type
of advanced visualization and you learn
about machine learning approaches and
you understand that how can you use you
know dimensionality reduction processes
or dimensionality reduction or
unsupervised machine learning processes
that can actually help you to find
needle from the haystack literally from
like large amount of data you'll be able
to find meaningful information using
some of these techniques and then you
will be learning about more statistical
and
advanced techniques that will help you
work on a project which is more related
to data analysis application of data
science and uh and machine learning and
all of that so we have detailed session
covering all of these important topics
and then we have a specialization that
you can opt for you can you can either
do both rf python or you can choose one
of these it's up to you but we will have
sessions for both rn and python so first
we will cover r and then we will cover
python so that you can understand
compare and for you know take advantage
of both of these uh
very very powerful
programming tools that helps biologists
that helps almost everyone in today's
era of data to gain meaningful insights
and show that in a proper presentation
and get recognition so that's about the
program that we are going to that we are
discussing and uh i think
uh
we have uh also like uh a different
dates which is to cover that which will
be covered in 45 in one month's time so
you'll have one month time where these
sessions are going to happen bi-weekly
and then uh you will have an opportunity
to discuss with the mentors and learn
about different sections and you will
also have the asynchronous coursework
associated with each of these sessions
so
those coursework are available on
learnomicslogic and you will be able to
get hold of that once you register and
also
once you
start the program so i'll just log out
and i'll just check because i'm already
a part of this program and
it's it's not showing me the
registration part so i'll just show you
the
registration part
so as you can see
the asynchronous material is also
included here you can click on these
links and go to the asynchronous
material and check
what all we will be covering in the
session along with that we have recorded
videos that we will be sharing with you
uh so that you can do it on your own if
you don't get time and we will also have
flexibility in terms of
in terms of scheduling meetings uh if
you are in us we will have a u.s team
supporting this and have a time
convenient
for all of us to have the meeting so
similarly you can choose between the
different subscription levels here and
uh also apply for scholarships if you're
from low income country and have
financial problems now uh just the last
part of the
presentation or the discussion
where we are going to discuss once you
have learned all of this once you have
mastered one of these techniques once
you have uh practiced on example data
sets the next thing that you would want
to do is to do it on a new problem
that is something that is like a
contribution to the research and the
scientific community because these
findings will be new and uh they are
eligible based on their nobility for
publications or for other uh poster
presentations and such recognition that
program is the research fellowship
program and now i like taking you
through this different uh different
types of opportunities so once you have
that like a research project a research
proposal there's an opportunity to
present that and publish that and all of
those uh
connect with the research community
using the mixed research symposium which
will be uh which is scheduled to be
happening in august so uh all of this
will make sense uh
to get a really good outcome from this
summer uh if you are uh if you're
interested if you are interested in
exploring some of these topics doing
some research and using the skill sets
for you for your future so uh some of
these key topics are also mentioned here
and this all has been you know kind of
covered we have excellent mentors who
will be supporting the program you can
watch the video from one of these basic
training sessions initial sessions for
everyone to be on the same page and then
this research fellowship program or
independent research project is the
highlight because uh here you will be
able to see that there are videos from
the students who completed or
and completed these research trainings
and come up with the wonderful outcomes
so let me explain or discuss couple of
case studies here uh i want to tell you
all about hannah one of the champions of
the program
so hannah worked on type 1 diabetes
type 1 diabetes is important to hannah
and her family
so
determining to the find the root cause
she turned to bioinformatics and joined
our collaborative omixlogic high school
training program
where she used a big data analysis tools
tool sets that combine uh combines
biology computer science and statistics
so uh let's uh take a look at her
project and if you are interested then i
can play the video
so let's play the video
hello my name is hannah davis from haiti
high school and my project is entitled
an in-depth look into identifying the
differentiation pathway and cell type of
the door receptor expressing lymphocytes
in type 1
a little bit of diabetes information
about my subject type 1 diabetes is an
autoimmune disease in which the body
attacks its own isolates of beta cells
within the pancreas the most common
treatment for type 1 diabetes is insulin
injection and the average sufferer
spends
6 000 to 7 000 yearly on insulin alone
diabetes is the disease of the immune
system which is the body's first defense
against intruders known as pathogens
immune system can be divided into the
passive active and responses within
these responses you're going to have
cells known as lymphocytes that
officiate immune response however when
the immune system does not work as work
as planned the immune cells target the
body's own functioning cells as faulty
cells and more central destruction
one new cell found in relation to type
one diabetes is the de cell the dual
receptor expressing lymphocyte is named
because it displays both a t cell
receptor and a b cell receptor and
according to the article in which the
cell was originally published these
cells are shown to mimic insulin
peptides to trigger diabetes-specific
helper t cells and although it could be
supported that the dd cells are driving
type 1 diabetes this was not explicitly
stated in the article that these cells
were originally published and it could
not be adequately concluded by other
scientists researching this topic
my project in order to interpret the
data i'll be using bioinformatics within
bioinformatics i'll be using rna-seq
analysis and within that i'll be using
differential gene expression analysis
so the purpose of my research is to
provide as much information as i can
about the dd cells to hopefully provide
insight
to see if these cells actually cause
type 1 diabetes and what their role is
in causing the disease furthermore
identifying the the cell to piping
differentiation pathway about of these
cells could provide insight into other
diseases as well as prevention and
reversion methods for typical diabetes
itself which currently do not exist
so the materials that i used first i
used the ncbi srn table from this file
project right here
and i chose
this data set because it's the original
data that the de cell was originally
published and the name of the article is
a public vcr present in a dual um in a
unique dual receptor expressing
lymphocyte from type 1 diabetes patients
encodes a potent t-cell autoantigen if
you're looking to find that on ncbi
and i also used a computer with the
capabilities converting my bioformatics
platform and used the tiber
bioinformatics tball info platform for
rna-seq analysis provided to me from
science coach i used to also use
microsoft excel to interpret my data
okay for my procedure first i downloaded
the sra running table from the bio
project in question then i input the
files into my platform selected two cell
types with three samples each to compare
to time then i ran a pipeline
specifically i chose the top hat cuff
merge cuff diff pipeline for
differential gene expression analysis
because it normally it output a
normalized expression count which could
be better
indicative of the expression of the set
as a whole since i only use three
samples and then i downloaded the gene
expression output files and drew
conclusions based on these outputs so
there's an example of some of the graphs
that i made this is the d cells top 50
express genes specifically within this
i'd like to point out the expression of
this natural killer grandson protein as
well as this immunoglobulin heavy
protein being in the top 50 as well as a
couple of these mitochondrial rna
genes being expressed which would
indicate a high proliferation rate of
this cell
here's the natural capillary gene
signature being expressed at very high
rates by the d cell but not so much by
the t and b self and to note that the
ink cell and t cell are very similar in
nature however the d cell is showing
that it is closer to a natural killer
cell rather than a t cell by expressing
more of these genes specifically i'd
like to point out perforin and some of
these chemicals that are being excreted
this is the b cell gene signature being
expressed by both the d e cell and the b
cell alike
here you can see that the de cells
expressing cytokines as well as the tcr
so in conclusion the decel is going to
possess lineage markers indicative of a
cd8nkt cell which suggests that the pe
cell
has b cell features because of its germ
encoded bcr and i was able to conclude
this because in the regional article it
stated that the bcr on the dep cell is
of germline configuration
and this supports the idea that the dd
cells are dual purpose cell
so this leads to the differentiation
pathway so you can see that the decel is
going to
follow a relatively standard
differentiation pathway of a natural
killer cell however within tcr
activation it's going to be activated by
self-antigen binding and it's going to
stop at the naive nkt so it's not
developed beyond that and after that
it's going to travel back to the bone
marrow where it's bcr is going to become
activated again by self antigen binding
is what i hypothesized um and i
concluded all this based on the
expression of different
cell markers being expressed as well as
the different
tcr
and bcr genes being expressed
so this is the proposed cell function
model here you can see the d e cell and
it's going to identify this beta so it's
lit through
so i'll pause it here but what i wanted
all for all of us to see is that
how you can use data
which comes out from the analysis which
can be done through easy steps and then
correlated with the biology and uh this
can be done within a very short period
of time uh once you learn about the how
to use uh the platform how to understand
from the coursework and run some
examples and
know how to do this by doing it yourself
uh practicing so uh
i mean this led to a lot of
accomplishments for hannah and you can
read a lot about
it from here numerous awards uh so many
that it will be difficult for me to read
out so please
so next uh
one of another uh
very gifted uh and
student andrus i want to discuss who
wants the prestigious potter mckinney
award uh so andres is from high school
at uh mexico in one of the high schools
in mexico and uh he was uh mentored by
all of us here and worked on a project
which was on in silicon transcriptomics
analysis of microbial glial cells that
led to a really innovative and
groundwork breaking work in uh one of
the
in some of this study for brain in your
neurodegenerative diseases that led to
uh let
anders to win uh the award and also get
an award for the award in biomedical and
health science category at one of the
very prestigious former company so um
maybe if we can quickly take a look at
his project uh initial part where his
describe is describing the problem so
that you understand that what different
students can come up with their
different ideas and can easily work by
finding the data set and then applying
some of these algorithms working with
the team
hello my name is andres modan
and i am a high school student from
mexico city i am currently an omics
logic bioinformatics research fellow and
i am truly passionate about biochemistry
systems biology and neuroscience
i am particularly interested in the
biological mechanisms that underlie
aging and neurodegenerative diseases
over the last three months i've been
working on my research project together
with my mentor dr harvey coy my research
project seeks to evaluate the role of
microbial cells in the pathogenesis and
progression of alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease is a progressive and
irreversible neurodegenerative disorder
that results in the development of
cognitive deficits and clinical dementia
alzheimer's disease is characterized by
the development of two pathological
hallmarks xenoplakes which are icy to
the aggregation of the amyloid beta
peptide and neurofibrillar rectangles
which arise due to the
hyperphosphorylation of the tau protein
although these two harmonics are widely
recognized as a two core pathologies of
alzheimer's disease the mechanisms by
which they are linked remain largely
unknown
over the last decade relevant
inflammation and in the pathogenesis and
progression of alzheimer's disease has
become more and more evident patients
that suffer from alzheimer's disease
show an elevated level of inflammation
in their brains
this inflammatory response in the brain
is mediated by microbial cells the
brain's resident macrophages
scientists have shown that the immune
activation of microbial cells leads to
secretion of pro-inflammatory cytokines
and the sympathetic response has been
shown to accessory both amyloid and
metal pathologies
therefore many scientists have begun to
appreciate um your inflammation as the
third core pathology of alzheimer's
disease as it may provide a link between
the accumulation of cenial plaques and
the later development of neurofibrillary
chemicals
the purpose of this research project was
to evaluate how the transcript of
microglial cells varies both
between physiological and pathological
conditions as well as how it changes
throughout aging
for my analysis i use the data from the
following study transcriptomic profiling
of microglia and astrocytes throughout
aging from panetta
um they still evaluated the
transcription of microglia and
astrocytes from both wildlife and apps
one mice these are double transgenic
mice that exhibit a remarkable elevation
of amyloid data aggregation
and the data that the study provides
yields valuable information regarding
microbial activation in response to
aging and amyloid data pathologies
i performed an rna set pipeline uh to
obtain a uh the expression levels in raw
returns as an output so to obtain a gene
expression table with the expression
values for the
yeah for the respective genes
uh and then using those raritan values
we performed an exploratory principle
component analysis uh to
see how the samples clustered and so
here we can see that there isn't really
a
clear clustering between wild type and
uh 80 samples but here we can see that
when we label our samples uh in terms of
age we can see that nine and twelve
twelve month old samples cluster apart
from two four and six month old samples
uh and based on this observation we
defined uh
two groups
uh
in terms of age so with the young
symbols which are two four and six month
old samples and the other samples which
are nine and twelve monthly samples
uh and yes so here we can see that uh
the young and the the young wildlife and
the young 80 samples clustered together
whereas the old welted and the old lady
samples are across zero part uh in the
lower region of the
of the
then we perform the differential
expression analysis uh
using uh d62
we perform these four different
differential expression analysis so
first we compare the transcription of
young av
uh and old ad samples so this allows us
to see how the transcript of microglial
cells vary throughout pathological aging
and we did the same uh by comparing
young wildlife and old wildlife samples
to see how the transcriptome varied
throughout the normal uh nonpathological
aging and then become very young while
different young 80s samples as well as
old wildlife and old ad samples um
to see the phenotypic differences at age
matched groups
uh and then here we quantify that the
number of differentially expressed genes
produced by each differential expression
analysis and we can see that the
greatest number of differentially
expressed genes
uh
were produced through it in the young
lady and old lady
meaning that there is a greater
phenotypic divergence throughout
pathological aging when compared to
normal non-pathological aging and here
we can see that there was a rather small
number
of differentially expressed genes
between the young samples which is
telling us that there isn't really a
kind of there aren't really a great fan
of the big differences between
samples and they support ch
related nature of alzheimer's disease as
one of the big differences between
healthy and diseased models arise
throughout age gene and they are not
present at a young age
here we performed uh here we perform
these volcano bloods and here we can see
that there is a greater phenotypic
divergence between the old wild type and
the old lady samples and the young kd
versus all these samples here we can see
that there aren't really there isn't
really a great number of differentially
expressed genes you can be young while
depending on these samples and here we
can see that although there is something
big divergence the number of
differentially expressed genes is not as
large in here as in the young lady
versus only these samples
uh then we perform principal component
analysis using only the expression
values from the differentially expressed
genes we
a differential expressed gene so those
that have a p value smaller than 0.05
and i love the full change value either
greater than 1.5 was 4 uh smaller than
minus 1.5 and then based on this we
perform the different clustering
analyses are the principle component
analysis i'm sorry and so here we can
see that there is clustering between
young lady and old lady samples here we
can see that um there is clustering
between all wild type and old led
samples
and here interestingly we could see that
there was also uh here there appeared uh
three clusters so here we see one with
two and fourth one those samples here we
see another one with uh
nine and twelve on those samples and
here we see one with a uh six-month-old
samples only which was
rather interesting and here we can see
that between the young valley and
younger samples they are like skiing
towards one of the axis and so there is
really a clear clustering or a
difference
between
the experimental groups
all right so here what i wanted all for
of you to understand is that
our in-depth understanding of the data
that you're using and
applying different type of visualization
methods as well as you know
based on the analysis refining your data
further can give give you very good
patterns that are
can differentiate and show clustering
differentiation in clustering and you
can group them and that would give you a
clear pattern so all of this pattern
recognition understanding finding and
doing big data analysis is uh sort of
possible within a short period of time
in this summer
through these training programs so i'll
just come go back to
the
the page
that
we were at
so
um this is the research fellowship
program the last program i wanted to
explain to all of you
uh and uh
the research fellowship program is
something that helps develop independent
research projects so if you think you're
ready to work on an independent research
project uh you're more than welcome to
join the research fellowship program
which is available for you to join
anytime now it is going to be it is
available since uh june 15th and uh
there's an opportunity to work in a 45
days project 60 days project or a
90 days project the dates are not so
much relevant here because uh you can
join any time and you can start working
on your project so similarly we have the
pricing and you can check out that and
decide which subscription you would want
and which program that you would want to
enroll to so that's uh that's the part
of my presentation and i hope uh all of
you have uh uh enjoyed this webinar and
learned a lot so if there are any
questions we'll be happy to take those
questions
all right if there are no more questions
uh we will conclude this session and we
look forward to for you to join the uh
join the programs or let other people
know who might be interested and who can
who can benefit from this training thank
you so much for joining today's session
and i hope that uh it would be
um
it would be great so there are a few
questions uh i'll just answer those so
dhruv is asking for a combined call so
dhruv um
if if we have your email address we can
share with you those
and provide the scholarship or any
discount if we can
so to answer there's a question from
charles so i wish to ask for scholarship
will it be different from the summer
training and any other on omix logic
platform
so the
obviously the the topics that we
discussed today charles and the pedagogy
that we discussed today that would be
the
path for the session uh for the programs
and for the training so i think you can
compare and uh compared to a
undergraduate or postgraduate level
course this will be a little slow paced
and it will be more
start from a very beginner level and
then we will move to different levels uh
based on the progress and the time that
one allocates
so
that would be the major difference i
would say
so thank you for sharing the scholarship
form
um and dhruvia we can reach out to you
uh if i think we if you have
pre-registered we will have your uh we
will have the information to reach out
to you so spurs can reach out to you
with the with the
cost for the three programs and the
scholarship or the discount code
all right so if there are any more
questions i'll be happy to answer those
okay thank you charles for uh for your
kind
wishes and uh thank you everyone for
joining today's session and i hope that
we get an opportunity to learn from each
other thank you so much
have a good day bye